cory booker mr potato head the worst
actor in the united states senate
he put on his angry eyes to question amy
coney barrett and then he blinked
very seriously and then he articulated
all of his words because he is the worst
and mouth man here is here is senator
cory booker from new jersey
questioning amy coney barrett on whether
she supports a white supremacy
yes i'm sure she i'm sure that she is a
member of the kkk with her two adopted
black children go senator booker
i want to just ask you very simply and i
imagine you'll give me a very short
resolute answer
um but you condemn white supremacy
correct
yes thank you i'm glad to see
that you said that i wish our president
she literally cannot believe would say
that so resolutely unequivocally as well
and she's like what in the f are you
talking about cory booker are you an
idiot and the answer is yes cory booker
is in fact
an idiot so like the looks i mean
i'm old enough to remember that vice
presidential debate where kamala harris
was was doing the
fake laugh and the weird smirk amy coney
barrett's facial expressions are so much
more slay queen than kamala harris's
it's not even close
she's looking at him like are you a
dumbass and the answer of course is
he is he is in fact a dumbass it got
even worse than that
so we'll save the the very very best for
last but
maisie hirono asked a couple of
questions one of them was so beyond the
pale stupid
that it is nearly impossible to describe
how stupid it is it was immediately
picked up by the media and turned into
a bizarre narrative they they literally
shifted dictionary definitions to meet
democratic
talking points we'll get to that in a
second but she also asked this was her
less dumb question
okay let's get to her lesson so maisie
hirono the stupidest person in the in
the united states and she is a
i mean a pure full-scale iq of a
potato
and i don't even mean like a baked
potato i mean like a raw potato pulled
directly from the ground a full-on tuber
pulled directly from a field
that is the brain power of maizie hirono
the democrat from hawaii
she asked acb randomly if she had ever
committed sexual assault
i'm going to go no on that one so we've
now been asked whether acb
likes white supremacy and also if she is
a rapist
did you just have this one left over
from the kavanaugh hearings or what
here's maisie hirono
i ask each nominee these two questions
and i will ask them of you
since you became a legal adult have you
ever made
unwanted requests for sexual favors or
committed any verbal
or physical harassment or assault of a
sexual nature
no senator hirono have you ever faced
discipline
or entered into a settlement related to
this kind of conduct
now senator she pranks hard not to laugh
right now
because what the hell you literally just
spent
time in a supreme court hearing asking a
catholic mother of seven
whether she has engaged in sexual
harassment or assault
yeah man yeah and then
we got sheldon whitehouse i mean this is
these are the people you elect folks
i have a question do you want to give
any of these people more power like
you can say that the republicans in the
senate are are idiots you can say that
the democrats and the senator idiots
okay if they're all idiots why do you
want to give them more power i don't
understand i really do not understand
americans keep saying how much they hate
congress and how much they hate the
president and how much they hate the
federal government and then they're like
but what if we gave them more power okay
here is brilliant
brilliant sherlock holmesian sleuth
sheldon whitehouse
from rhode island yeah this guy is just
this is
this is me trying to explain you know
talmudic injunctions about how to set up
an a roof
to people who don't even know what a jew
is this is like what is he even doing
right here
i don't i don't know he takes out a
chart to explain how this is all driven
by
money
he takes out a chart he he first took
out a chart i have to say he took out a
big sign and it said the scheme
as though it was one of those act breaks
in a tarantino film
he broke like a placard said the scheme
and then you sort of expected
you know like tom sizemore to walk out
and start speaking in jargon
to harvey keitel or something he said
the scheme
okay then he uh he takes out a sign
that has on it a bunch of words that
have very little to do with each other
and a bunch of money signs
and he starts explaining this thing like
charlie day and it's always
it's always sunny in philadelphia uh
here here we go sheldon whitehouse and
by the way the point that he's making is
that conservative groups want
conservative justices appointed
that's his point and he starts like
taking yarn
and using it like carry on homeland to
make one of these giant fbi boards
sheldon white house genius sherlock
holmes and sleuth
in all cases there's big anonymous money
behind various
lanes of activity one lane of activity
is through the conduit of the federalist
society
it's managed by a guy was managed by a
guy named leonard leo
and it's taken over the selection of
judicial nominees
all the same funders over and over again
bringing the cases
and providing this orchestrated
orchestrated chorus
of amiki then the same group also funds
the federalist society over here
it was an 80 to zero five to four
partisan
route ransacking
that clip and then there's a cutaway to
lindsey graham and graham's like
what what did they put in this guy's
coffee what in the world
is going on it did not go great for
sheldon whitehouse by the way
uh cruz then blowtorched sheldon
whitehouse he pointed out you know who
spends an awful lot of money on
on legal issues everyone including the
left
is sometimes for good sometimes for bad
and the fact is
that the the court system in the united
states has routinely been used in order
to
make certain laws illegal in order to
strike down certain laws
in the the entire rosa parks heroic
story was orchestrated by the naacp i
mean it was not
it was not that rosa parks spontaneously
decided to sit down on the back of the
bus it was well planned
with other local leaders like this sort
of stuff has been done for
years on end right brown versus board
was a legal strategy that was undertaken
by the naacp like
this notion that that political groups
don't spend money
in the in the realm of law is bizarre
here is cruz just going after sheldon
whitehouse and blow torching him
the senator from rhode island talked
about big corporate powers
without acknowledging that the
contributions from the fortune 500 in
this presidential election
overwhelmingly favor joe biden and the
democrats
so all of the great umbrage about
the corporate interest are spending dark
money
is wildly in conflict
with the actual facts that the corporate
interests that are spending dark money
are funding the democrats
okay that of course is exactly true did
you know that every like on this video
creates one additional leftist tier
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity
hit the like button